[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q a number 79.
so are there any questions this week
there are a lot of questions this week
there are a lot of questions
and i love that we get so many questions
and i always feel a little bad because i
know that means there's a higher
percentage
of questions that we won't get to uh and
um the sort that we do in real time is
very rough
so often we miss questions that are
great so i'm going to turn over a new
leaf and just
talk faster and more succinctly and to
see how that goes
no you're not no no no well it didn't
last
go for it i'll try to but i don't think
it'll work we'll see we'll see
okay uh we'll begin with a few questions
from last week can expensive low utility
stuff like jewelry
um and the expectation that men buys it
hold on what was that i don't know the
cat did something under the table
yeah he's uh he's sending us a message
that our failure to give him treats
during the break really has been noticed
okay
yes okay um i'm gonna i'm gonna start
over
can expensive low utility stuff like
jewelry and the expectation that men
buys it
be explained as a javian costly signal
of fitness or something else
uh yeah yeah you nailed it it's uh the
term the the idea goes back to thorsten
veblen
conspicuous consumption and zahavi
doesn't cite felt one does he
it's a hobbyist i don't think zahavi
does cite
thirst in veblen but clearly conspicuous
consumption is
the right modality to think about it
however i would say
that that the reason that the signal
works is that it is not entirely
unfakable but it is unfakable at a
particular level and so if you think
about
somebody drinking an expensive bottle of
wine it could be that they have spent
their last 50 bucks on a 50
bottle of wine but if you see somebody
drinking a 50 bottle of wine it's a lot
more likely
that they have 50 bucks to burn and so
anyway
especially if somebody engages in
repeated signaling of that
kind it tends to be indicative of
resources so yes
um yeah boy there's just a lot more i
want to say here
um i had not actually ever put those two
things explicitly together before um so
this is uh
zach you just show quickly this is the
paper uh
in question um you know from which a lot
of interesting sexual selection theory
stemmed
um zahavi from 1975 made selection a
selection for a handicap
um but i think you're right i just don't
even know when i'm so much less familiar
with like the social science
literature i don't know when uh was was
writing i think maybe decades earlier
yep potentially much earlier maybe yeah
maybe more than decades but um in any
case
uh yeah i actually did have this exact
connection
in the chapter of my dissertation that i
was
forced to remove oh yeah yeah so anyway
yes
but conspicuous consumption is the right
neighborhood i should say i'm a limited
fan of zahavi
i don't believe the pure zahavi
handicapped principle
is accurate but i believe the reality of
sexual displays is in the neighborhood
of of handicap yeah so apparently um
it was in his in veblen's theory of the
leisure class
where he introduced the concept of
conspicuous consumption which was
as you were maybe getting at published
in 1899.
there you go 1899. yeah so
um surprising there anyway that's all
probably of no interest to almost anyone
but here
here we are okay next question um a warm
day in winter
walking in woods i follow an odd sound
to a tree in which about 70 squirrels
were barking
have you heard of such behavior wait
what 70 squirrels seven
one tree um certainly the the barking
and sometimes you know several in nearby
trees at one another but
70 in one tree i've never never can you
describe the fungal environment
around this area did you encounter any
interesting mushrooms that you or the
squirrels ingested
right well i think there's only one well
flying squirrels eat truffles
i don't think other squirrels eat
mushrooms very very regularly
but i do think that this question 70
squirrels in are you sure
are you i mean that's awesome that's
awesome if it happened and i beat you
know where yeah so there's no indication
here of the location
except that um there's a forest and
there's winter
which you know narrows it down somewhat
but not sufficiently there's
two bands of latitude
but forest there's lots of places on the
temperature
it's not forested yeah that's true
that's true yeah
um so no in short um but fascinating
bless you sorry how do you think the
null hypothesis works in regards to
taking the covid vaccine
i have a friend who thinks the null
hypothesis would be that taking the
vaccine has no long-term effects
i'm not sure so i thought this was um
important to just try to respond but i'm
not even sure how to frame oh i
i i got it okay um
the uh so first of all you don't want to
confuse
the null hypothesis with a
prescription for the course of action
right the null hypothesis is about the
presumption of what is likely
right the precautionary principle i
would say when you're talking about
issues of health
sits on top of that so maybe that's why
i'm confused by the question that you
know null hypothesis and what should i
do
isn't the same kind of those two things
don't interact yeah you need a layer you
need like a moral layer
or a judging layer on top of the
scientific layer in order to
decide what to do right exactly so i
would say
the question of null hypothesis painting
with a broad brush null hypothesis is a
description of where the presumption
ought to be and
the presumption
of long-term hazard ought to be that
there
isn't one unless the
number of systems interacted with and
similar influences
are such that you know uh you know the
null hype uh
i guess it wouldn't be a null hypothesis
but in any case the
precautionary principle says in the area
of your health you ought to
treat harm as presumed in order to
protect yourself it does not
tell you to expect harm on the basis of
it being
most likely right it so the point is
it is a it is a choice to err in a
particular
direction so as to remain safe
that that is true that is about the
precautionary principle though not about
the null hypothesis i i persist
in my sense that i'm not sure how to
apply null hypothesis to a question of
um
you know does the covid vaccine
have long-term effects or not
well i i mean i think it's clear
at the level of null hypothesis we
assume
it doesn't have long-term effects until
we've seen that it does
but we should behave as if it will
because that makes us safer
okay um
uh this is from the discord this this
week
statement man-made climate change
resulting from increasing co2 content in
the atmosphere is driven by man's use of
fossil fuels
this is the existential problem of our
time and all of society needs to be
radically restructured in order to
prevent catastrophe
so that was one part what do you think
about the so-called scientific consensus
on this notion and what does this say
about the perversion of science as you
see it in context of the horde
performance of science
on covet 19.
okay um i would say
one i don't trust scientific consensus
in some sense scientific consensus
unless
it has a very specific route
that it arrived is an oxymoron
right so science leaping to consensus on
complex matters
is evidence of something gone wrong
i do think the climate is changing as a
result
of anthropogenic activity especially the
release
of uh these uh
light these energy trapping compounds
into the atmosphere
in my case i think in your case we
believe that
because it does not depend on complex
models where the scientific consensus
matters
it depends on very simple phenomena
and very simple observations which we
can check
and so um part of the confidence that
this
is a serious problem comes from yes not
perfectly conclusive but certainly very
provocative observations
about plumes of methane being released
from the arctic for example
glacial melt but i would say glacial
melt is actually a really good indicator
of where we are
because the most alarming proposals
about where we
were with respect to climate change
would have suggested an ice-free arctic
you know by last summer for for example
is that right i mean i saw many but i
certainly saw
that projection and of course it failed
there are still glaciers
on mount kilimanjaro they have retreated
substantially there are glaciers in
glacier national park they have
retreated substantially
and so what i would say is something is
clearly going on
it does appear to be anthropogenic it's
very dangerous in the long run
especially if you understand the amount
of methane trapped in a frozen
form in the arctic and the possibility
that it will be
released in a way that causes severe
positive feedback
which could then cause human
interference in the system to be
a minor contributor so anyway there's
every reason to take it seriously
but there's also every reason to imagine
that those who take it seriously have
enforced a kind of discipline on what
can be said that has artificially
um silenced evidence that goes in the
direction that it may not be going as
fast as we think
or be as dangerous etc so i'm very
concerned about the consensus i'm also
very concerned about global warming
and i think all of these cases
in which we see a rush
to a scientific consensus you know the
lab leak being a primary example
the fact that people circled the wagons
around the idea
that anybody who thought that this
leaked from a lab was obviously
unsophisticated biologically and didn't
understand what goes on in the
laboratory or what technologies were at
people's disposal
that turned out to be garbage some of us
could see very clearly that it was
garbage from the beginning
and it required impossibly high levels
of immunity and endurance to get
through the stage where now we can
finally talk about it in public
what does that say about the hazard of
vaccines
what we can't seem to discuss in public
now
is you know it's lagging the lab leak
discussion but
we're headed in the same direction we're
now beginning to talk about the
complexities of these technologies we
don't understand
so okay now you've got climate change
you've got uh the laboratory possible
laboratory origin of the virus you've
got
vaccine safety and if you keep going
into these big fields that study complex
phenomena you will find this repeated
again and again and again so what it
says is something about
the mechanism has allowed too much
politics or too much market force
to influence the study that really
requires insulation from those things in
order to be done properly
that's excellent i guess the only thing
i would have to add is that um
unfortunately many of the scientists uh
who are investigating these complex
systems
a are actually trained in reductionist
science as opposed to
in emergent science and they're buying
their own press
that they there seems to have been
and i suspect that it just happened as
opposed to
it was designed but who knows um
a a conclusion that the american and
maybe the entire world but certainly the
american populace
is just too stupid uninformed
uninterested
to understand uh complex scientific
findings and so
we're not not only aren't we going to
assume that you can but we're not going
to let you be exposed to the information
at all we're not we're not going to let
you go there
we're going to tell you what you have to
accept and and move on from there
and you know i do think you know as
exactly this question suggests
as much as um you know
you and i are in a very different place
with regard to what we actually think is
going on regarding anthropogenic climate
change
and uh you know in terms of
we both have seen evidence that we find
deeply compelling of anthropogenic
climate change across
many systems whereas for
many months the uh the mainstream
science that we were being told we
needed to accept
uh was exactly the mainstream science on
covid that that we were
arguing against um and yet the
authoritarian
methods by which we are told that we
must accept it seem
nearly identical and i feel like that
that toolkit just got sort of lifted
and moved over you know from from
from climate change space to coveted
space and that's
that's appalling for additionally
the reason that now we're going to have
even more people
questioning um the legitimate results
over in climate change space
and also the legitimate results over in
college space like science remains this
process
that we need that is the best it's you
know it's inefficient but it remains the
best method we have
for getting to an understanding of what
is true in the world and
we've got these inane hashtags like
trust the science and follow the science
and
people who hear that and hear the
garbage coming out of people's mouths
will go well i will never trust the
science or the scientists again and
like no everyone has almost everyone on
earth
has or has had the capacity to
understand enough about
how to understand what is true via the
scientific method to assess some of
these things
on your own and mostly we're just not
being
allowed to even access the information
yes
and um i i think it is worth
um adding one arguably more trivial
uh instance to our list here because
it makes the point in one way it makes
the point
more extremely than any of the others
this has to do
with masks in the outside environment
and the reason i raise this is that one
way to look at it is you know an
abundance of caution causes you to wear
a mask outdoors when you don't need it
and that's not a huge problem it isn't a
huge
problem but it is a problem it does
interfere with normal social
interactions and we have no idea how
much of the breakdown of
normal social interactions is uh being
accelerated by such things and it does
interfere a little bit with the creation
of vitamin d which does protect you from
covid and so it'd probably be good to
have more
skin exposed i think it's actually a
huge problem so you know it makes people
less likely to go outside because
outside is now not that much different
from inside so they're more likely to be
inside where they're more likely to get
the damn disease in the first place
where they're outside they might be
actually exercising where they're going
to be healthier
they're going to become therefore more
resistant to the disease and bad
um bad ramifications of the disease like
everything about it is actually
um dangerous and the the you know the
what what's the harm
people remind me very much of the like
if you don't have anything to hide then
you shouldn't care about privacy
well no you're misunderstanding things
at a really fundamental
level i agree about this i do think any
individual instance of wearing a mask
when you don't need one
is trivial the net effect of a year of
wearing them when we didn't need them
is anything but trivial so there's some
sort of
conflict between those two things but
the thing that struck me as i was
considering this particular puzzle was
outside almost
all of the world is outside right it's
99 plus of the world is not indoors
and so a regime
in which you imagine you're in jeopardy
of kovid
anywhere you encounter a person makes
99 of the world that is actually
probably plenty safe threatening
so what kind of lie is it that takes
that fraction of the world and causes
you to fear what might happen to you
there
when in fact the the useful thing
at the point that kovid descended and we
lost our opportunity
to control it and there's a lot to be
said about what might have been done
back in
march of last year or whatever
but at the point you've lost control of
covid
we needed to take a deep breath and say
look this is
bad but there are some things about it
that are a lot better than they might be
here's one you don't have to worry about
surfaces
that makes the complexity of making
yourself safe that much
less second outdoors
you're almost perfectly safe and we need
to jealously guard
these two things right we need to not
give it a path to
learn these tricks of being spreading on
services or
spreading outside or spreading to the
young which it is now seeming to learn
right but the point is we had these
opportunities we were robbed of a lot
but we were also given some
opportunities and the consensus that
lied about
outside and is now not even
acknowledging that that's what happened
but pretending that maybe it's
time to lift the requirement on masks
outside
when in fact it was always time to do
that right well and specifically it's
being framed as if um you know
it's only safe if you're vaccinated
right yeah another
another uh one of these uh uh perks
that's going to be offered in order to
right and everybody else and another way
to just completely confuse the logical
discussion you know in what
i i can't even see my way to following
the logic
of you can be masked outside if you're
not
if you're vaccinated but not if you like
i i don't see how
that works and frankly i've seen now a
couple of examples of schools
who are treating masks as um reward and
punishment
where like uh ins like i won't be able
to call it up right now but you know if
some some group of kids if they won some
competition they got to go without a
mask for 20 minutes
and if they came in second they got to
go without a mouse for 10 minutes
like how about if we talk about seat
belts instead
hey hey honey you won your baseball game
so you get to ride home without your
seatbelt
like what kind of complete lack of
recognition
you know either this is simply
performative this is all theater
right and they know it and and and those
administrators at that school know it
which they don't right um
or this is actually providing safety in
which case how
dare you use it as a carrot and a stick
for children
who are trying to develop a sense of
what to do and how to be in the world
and we'll begin to see all rules as
theater yeah right
you know all rules aren't theaters some
things actually provide safety
and some things don't and we should
reduce the number of things in the
second category and increase the number
of things in the first category
and not not conflate them and not be
like well a rule is a rule
no no it's not so i guess the upshot of
all of this
is that where we can check what we find
is rampant use of
the authoritative voice of science to
spread stuff that's doing
other things and it's driving some of us
crazy and i think you and i are in the
fortunate position
because we've been trained in science to
offer some corrective but boy is the
pushback
incredible when you just try to say the
obvious things
and so anyway yes it's uh it does
diagnose the system
yeah um now i will point out that your
uh
opening top of the hour uh decision to
be uh
concise and fast has has not gone well
so far so we're like a half an hour
i haven't started that party i see okay
well now we're gonna do it okay okay
i have sugar ants in my new portland
apartment it breaks my heart to see them
walk into traps and die
do these small creatures have any
self-awareness or emotions are they
conscious or are they basically machines
i still hate to see them die and this
from someone who identifies themselves
as lefty but not loony
i appreciate it well uh i'm going to
work from what i know about sugar ants
which is that they are ants um
i actually i've never heard of sugar
ants is that a special category of ant
yeah okay um glance all right so i don't
know if it's
if it's a if it's a good group
photogenically but yeah it's a term that
people use
all right so here's here's what i
suspect
um and i think this i've thought about
this a lot because
there's uh there's a question about how
to
how to allocate your compassion and i do
not believe
that there is any reason to suspect
that arthropods which includes insects
which includes
ants have a subjective experience of
the world that does not thinking that
they have a subjective experience does
not help us explain anything that we can
observe about their behavior that we
can't explain
with uh automatic algorithms in
neuron form so what that says is we
can't be certain that they don't have
subjective experience
but we don't have a reason to believe
that they do
um and therefore we should probably
assume that they are
little robots in the narrow sense which
don't experience
uh torment or pain
they have circuits that cause them to
behave as if they do because those
circuits work for the same reason that
circuits that do allow you to have
torment or pain work so i would say
i wouldn't torture these animals because
you can't be sure of that but i wouldn't
be too worried about
the fact of causing them to expire i
would
default to mechanisms that don't toxify
your environment and don't torture them
more than necessary but i will say
all of those creatures are headed for
death in one way or another
that that's what happens in nature and
you know you can't you can't let the
mosquitoes in your house
survive because you're afraid to do away
with them likewise you can't have
ants raiding your pantry okay well
uh we need to move on but uh i agree
with everything you said except the idea
that
they're all headed for death one way or
another that's that's a terrible
argument we're all headed for death one
way or another i think that's an
absurd argument well i'm only making it
in the context of the other argument
i've made which is that i don't think
that their suffering is suffering
i can't be certain of that but in terms
of figuring out that doesn't have
anything to do with the fact that
they're going to die eventually
we're going to die too but we do suffer
no but in some sense
at the point that you establish a
building right
you are saying i'm going to reduce the
amount of habitat and therefore i'm
going to reduce the number of creatures
that would live in this habitat by some
amount you're effectively signing
creatures
up for failing to exist and so the only
question then
is is the animal suffering in my
eliminating it or am i just following
through on the commitment i've already
made by establishing
that makes sense that makes sense
all right a few weeks ago you endorsed
expressvpn they know everything about
your internet usage
if someone hacks them or buys their
company then all of your activity will
be exposed can you say something about
why you are not worried about this
uh well yeah i can say that
uh i am in no position to know for
certain
but what i believe is present
is a insulation of
meaningful information from capture by
somebody who would purchase the company
so in in some sense i think uh
the assumption that all of this
information is
captured and therefore purchasable is an
error if that
is uh wrong i'd be very interested to
know it because it's an obvious
vulnerability so
i'm open to input but that is my that is
my belief in why
i'm comfortable with such an endorsement
yeah i agree with that
do you have any thoughts on the roundup
herbicide glyphosate
and predicted rising rates of autism in
the coming decades
is this just youtube hysteria or
something legitimate to pay attention to
i have not explicitly seen a connection
made between glyphosate and autism
but i've seen a connection made between
glyphosate and lots of other things
compellingly that we do not want and i
find glyphosate to be one of the
horsemen of the apocalypse yeah i agree
glyphosate is
very dangerous how dangerous we don't
know in part because monsanto spends
such a huge sum shouting down anybody
who
attempts to raise proper alarm about it
and so
anyway yeah i think this is one of these
places where
we scientists are supposed to say
certain things about
gmos right gmos are safe that's supposed
to be our line and then we're supposed
to explain that you
and the public don't understand that
genes have been modified in organisms by
people for thousands of years since this
really isn't any different and the fact
is that's a nonsense analysis and the
public is not in a position necessarily
to know why it's a nonsense analysis
but glyphosate is one such reason right
the the
pairing of roundup with roundup ready
crops is really what the story
of uh of gmos needs to engage
and so i can't say anything about autism
either i don't know anything about that
connection i have no reason
to think it's a thing but i would
certainly be open to evidence that it
was it wouldn't
shock me um welcome to complex systems
so
yeah you're intruding in a complex
system with a novel molecule
um but yeah it's a it's a it's a
dangerous game we're playing and just
the simple amount of glyphosate that is
being used
in industrial farming is enough to
cause really substantial worry
okay next question as a woman who truly
believes in equality of opportunity
and not outcomes can i in good
conscience apply for a job which i know
is only open to female applicants
the job description is otherwise deeply
appealing to me
i think so um but i guess i'm surprised
i didn't know i didn't know that that
was happening
that there were um jobs um specific
there's obviously a lot of this going on
sort of behind the scenes
and some types of job positions that are
being
produced they're being created out of
thin air that are you know only for
people of color or for women and such
and you know
it says it's open but it's pretty clear
that it would be very hard to get hired
if you
had a particular demographic marker
which should itself be against the law
of course um so i'm curious
um i'm curious what kind of job this is
um
and frankly if it's actually only open
to female applicants
that being explicit makes me feel better
about it
than if it's this hidden thing um and
everyone thinks that they can apply
equally and then you don't
and actually it was it was decided in
advance that only a certain subset if
you fulfilled certain demographic
qualities
would be able to get the job
you know i i would hope that you could
do something to speak
against such kinds of higher end
practices in the future were you to get
the job yeah i would say you need to be
very careful
to the extent that those who have values
that would
suggest this isn't a proper way to hire
don't take the job because they don't
want to be sullied by it it means that
those who would make such decisions are
empowered more
so if vaccines work the way they're
advertised in terms of granting immunity
why would a vaccinated person ever have
to worry about an unvaccinated person
why still wear masks post facts if the
receiver is vaccinated as well
um it's gonna be about breakthrough
cases i think i think the only the only
thing that i can think of and i have
given this some thought
um is that you know some number of
people who get vaccinated still can get
sick with the disease
um that said um
part of being vaccinated is obviously
about actually
not getting the disease and part of it
is about being able to return to
the life that you had before so um
i i don't know why we are being told
that vaccinated people need to be
worried about unvaccinated people
um you know so it's true at a
tiny level that you could get sick if
you're vaccinated
um but i think more
to the point this is once again not
science but social control this is about
this is about messaging and narrative
and uh reinforcing the you know like
uh the good people get vaccinated and
the bad people um
resist and you know and we can keep
going down
and going down the lines of you know all
of us will fall into
at least one of these camps where
suddenly we're not the good person
anymore
and um and once that happens once you
recognize that you go like wow
you're not actually using logic with me
you're just you've just decided that i'm
not your tribe and therefore you can
hate me
yeah i think it's about punishing
independence
and uh it's also about making simple
rules that do not force you to
acknowledge a complexity
you know the idea that people who have
had kovid should obviously get the
vaccine too
that is anything but obvious and the
problem is
if you say well actually people who've
had covid
don't need the vaccine because they've
effectively had a vaccine
and these vaccines are more dangerous
than
they should be because we know nothing
about their long-term effect so
it's better to keep those people from
having the extra risk if you say that
you've what there's risk right so you've
done that so instead we're going to
expose lots of people to risk that they
don't need to face
i mean this is part of what i we tried
to get at i think a few weeks ago
when i was alarmed at the
um i don't remember if it was fizer and
moderna but one of the ceos said yeah
actually we think there's gonna be need
to be yearly boosters
and um you know it is what it is you
know either either that's
true that this is more like a flu
vaccine than like a yellow fever vaccine
or not
um but um if that's the case then having
had covid is not you know it's not going
to provide lifetime immunity
and it may you know is it yearly is it
twice yearly is it once year
every other year you know who why did we
just land on every year because that's
easy to put on your calendar
um in the case of flu because it's
seasonal um but is coveted seasonal
we kind of thought it might be but now i
don't know you know it's it's really
hard
to tell that the data just are we're not
being shown the data in a clear way
and so you know if the vaccines are
everything that we hope they are
um having had covid doesn't provide
lifetime immunity it seems
and therefore in order to be protected
you you know perhaps should should be
expected to get vaccinated at some point
that said increasingly now
uh code vaccination is being required to
do stuff
like go back to school uh and
uh and people are saying well it's just
like you know just like the mmr vaccine
it's like well the mmr vaccine is once
as an adult and maybe you get
every 10 years your title is checked and
i don't actually even remember if that's
the case but it may just be once as an
adult
that's very different from if suddenly
we were told
you're required to get a flu vaccine and
i'm not equating fluent code but i never
have but
it's very different from being told you
need to get a re-up on a vaccine every
single year
well there are two things in play one
is the decay of your existing immunity
and the other is the evolution of the
virus and its
need for a new vaccine that's up to date
yes and you've made this clarification
before and i
and i confused i didn't confuse them i
just didn't specifically
yeah um but the they're really very
different
and uh which one of these or both that
we're dealing with is important and the
fact that
we know very little right we're learning
a lot about how this thing is evolving
now
how it's evolving in response to the
vaccine is a very important question
and then there's another question which
is how long does your immunity last to
the initial
uh variant um
you know maybe it does last a lifetime
but that doesn't buy you it doesn't get
you out of
boosters if the thing is evolving uh at
a rapid enough rate yeah
yeah that's right um
mrna vaccine particles can't
self-replicate so
much less quantity of cells that can
even produce spikes compared to a covet
infection
quantity quantity matters so vaccines
are probably very safe by comparison
so that was hard to read but i i
i suspect this is right right and this
is what we talked about at length right
um
in in the first hour um you know
comparatively i suspect that the
vaccines are safer than
organic exposure to covid well i think
we can
part say that that's very likely based
on just how devastating covid
turns out to be and over what a range of
tissues and all of that that's
almost certainly true but it's it's the
wrong comparison
right because the category that is
safest from harm
is no covet no vaccine now the other
thing
and again i think it's just the lurking
concern that is not discussed with
respect to these novel vaccines
is what cells are taking them up what
fraction of the cells that are supposed
to take them up
take them up in order to produce this
immunity
right so if they're highly effective at
producing this immunity
but there's a wide variance in how many
cells take them up or what cells take
them up
then what that means is that even at the
low
end of that they are producing immunity
which means some people may be getting
these things in
many more cells than they need in order
to get the immunity
and those cells are going to be targeted
by the immune system and killed so
tissue damage is
going to be done is it better than covid
yep if i had to pick between risking
the vaccine and risking covid i'd risk
the vaccine
but given the ability potentially to
dodge cobit behaviorally
uh this is not such a clear question
yeah i mean i guess
um something that occurred to me we were
talking just then
that is also true is that for many
people who are
on the fence who are concerned about
this
particular vaccine in in part because of
the kind of analysis that
you just gave if these are people who
are also
eating crap food and taking over the
counter drugs
or on other pharmaceuticals then
there is a good chance that they're
experiencing so much tissue damage
and um you know early aging and
risk of disease from the other stuff you
know
and not to mention the environmental
stuff that many of us don't have
you know control over that you know the
poorer you are the more likely you are
to be inhaling
crap just because of where you are
living um
that that you know compared to a
lifestyle in which you
have the you know the freedom and luxury
to really
not be taking in almost anything that
isn't
you know food that is that it has some
resemblance to the organism from which
it came
and you're not taking over the counter
stuff and like you all of this
compared to that this risk is
higher because you're introducing it
into a system that has far
fewer such contaminants already whereas
most modern people are ingesting so many
contaminants on a regular basis
that the risk is relatively smaller
agreed and in an adjacent place
is i think the um
the question or the assertion in this
question
does not then notice the fact
that the younger you are the less
destructive this disease seems to be
and so one possibility is that if the
questioner is right
that there's some place where your
apparent immunity to damage from covid
declines to the point that the damage
that you risk with the vaccine
is worthwhile in other words you can
imagine two crossing curves and there'd
be some age at which this was
a trade worth making right that's easily
conceivable
rather than a it's better than the
disease well
it's better than the disease imagine
some
you know coefficient right or a linear
process where we have
something else in evidence so um
you know let's i mean we can have that
discussion we've got all of that
we've been having it we need to have
that discussion more widely
yeah yeah we got to get through a few
more of these before we go to the next
uh hour i'd love to hear your thoughts
about the idea that looks at cancer as a
breakdown in the genetic regulatory
system enforcing multicellular
cooperation where cancer cells act more
like competitive unicellular
organisms i'm not familiar with this
idea well you know it's
kind of right there's some value in
thinking of it this way
but because very few cancers are in a
position to pass themselves
on from one creature to the next there's
no
long-term adaptation towards this
strategy the strategy yeah
almost always self-defeating and because
it's almost always self-defeating
this is a useful lens to look at it
right that effectively
there is inevitable selection for cells
that behave as if they were
competing in the body but it's largely
an illusion
right so that's good yeah i think i
think you did it yep
um oh so this actually i think we
already addressed this but evergreen
also announced everyone required to be
vaccinated
if you were still happily teaching there
would you comply
so i don't know but which job would you
prefer
president of evergreen or mayor of
portland um
um at this point mayor of portland yeah
100
i don't want either job but yeah but
portland is probably savable
yeah i think portland is savable and i
don't you know this you this
makes me less sad with every passing
week and that itself makes me sad but
um i don't think evergreen is savable at
this point i mean
we'll give them this news from this week
yeah what are they doing let's put it
this way the only reason it still exists
is that there have been huge infusions
of cat cash to get it through
the lean times and it's not behaving in
a way that will get itself out of the
ditch
yeah um
i've forgotten what the first part of
that question uh would you would you
comply with mandatory vaccination i had
just seen this actually f
in the fall all staff faculty and
students who are required to be
vaccinated
um no i would have uh come out publicly
against my employer trying to force that
and we would have had many of the
discussions that we've had on dark horse
well there's actually a nice and i think
at evergreen i think at some of these
other places too they said um
religious medical or personal exemptions
available
it's like well okay how about scientific
exemptions can we can we add scientific
to religious exemptions come on
right uh yeah so yeah
smart of them to make an exemption thing
but then what does the policy mean
you know i mean i think that sort of
thing i've never seen the word personal
added to this but um
this exists for for mandatory
vaccinations for school-aged children
right
i mean our children were fully
vaccinated um we waited as long as
possible
as as one really would want to um
but we also knew people who uh pursued
exemptions
and uh we didn't agree with that choice
but you know
there was there has for all of these i
think now
actually i'm not sure for international
travel right like i never
i never had a student when i was leading
students into the amazon and we needed
yellow fever vaccinations
um i did have a couple say what if i
don't want it like then you can't go
like i'm not in a position to argue with
the ecuadorian military on this front
like
sorry um and again as i've said before
you know yellow fever vaccination is
decades old you know literally decades
of safety and efficacy data
and it's not our right to go into a
place where disease is endemic and risk
putting the people who live there at
risk right it's just a different
situation
um but um for all of the sort of
homegrown
vaccine requirements i think that there
are always
exemptions religious and medical
exemptions
well so this raises the obvious question
about
vaccine passports and whether they're
going to be exemptions there
i certainly hope so but my expectation
is absolutely not
uh can family members who got the coping
19 shot be sick with covet unknowingly
with mild or no symptoms and get other
family members sick
yes unfortunately it's rare presumably
but again breakthrough cases
i would say well so breakthrough cases
by breakthrough cases you mean variance
i mean no
i mean people again the data are crap
but what i have seen reported in the
media
is that some people who get vaccinated
still get sick with covid and can
therefore pass it on because they when
they do when vaccinated people do get
sick they tend to be
low symptomatic or asymptomatic and so
they might
i think therefore be slightly more
likely
to pass it on because not only are they
non-symptomatic but because they're
vaccinated they think they couldn't
possibly have it
right so non-symptomatic uh
or low symptomatic they may be less
contagious but so i would point out
again here's there's a hidden dichotomy
too because there are people who are
fully vaccinated who are nonetheless
sick and contagious at whatever level
they are
and then there's the vandenbosch point
which is people on the way to being
immune are not fully immune and they may
be in danger of spreading a variant
or selecting for a variant that they
could then pass on which would be even
more dangerous because it would be uh it
would evade
existing immunities from either having
coveted already or
from being vaccinated so the next
question actually um speaks to his
argument as well is bush's argument
about vaccines
similar to the concern over
antibiotic-resistant super bacteria
if other nations are going to over
vaccinate any way shouldn't we
it's a tragedy of the commons that's
really two questions in there but
um it does seem analogous to antibiotic
resistance
yes in every way but one and i want to
think through the one
very very carefully but antibiotic
resistance
there's actually a solution for us
at whatever point we get wise enough to
decide to take it
right which is yeah if you want to take
your antibiotics out of circulation for
a long enough period of time you can
restore
the utility of them and that's because
all of that antibiotic resistance has a
cost and if it's not paying back
because the antibiotic in question isn't
in the environment so it's not favoring
the variants that have the resistance
it will go away so you can reset that
clock i
don't know of an analogous mechanism
that will allow you to reset covid um
kovid appears to be like running on a
treadmill
rather than some research well it's yeah
it's not
actually really analogous in this way
because
with antibiotic resistant super bacteria
um
incomplete application of the
antibiotics
is allowing the bacteria to become
resistant to them so you take the
antibiotics out
of circulation entirely for say 30 years
or whatever the amount of time would be
and then upon reintroduction those
bacteria that have since
evolved many many many thousands
hundreds of thousands of generations
um are now naive to those antibiotics
whereas
um there's no it's just not the same
logic with vaccines and and covet it's
not about
you don't you don't want naivete well
let's put it this way because we're
talking about a virus
yeah the calculus is very different
because the thing that causes the
antibiotic resistance to disappear is
that the bacteria or
fungi are organisms
and that means that they have
conservation laws that they are paying
the price for things but viruses
borrow all of their physiology from the
creature that they infect and it's a
very different calculus i'm not sure
that there's nothing analogous but i
don't even know i know how to
fix a uh uh antibiotic that's no longer
working i don't know how
to do the same trick for um for
vaccines i agree exactly right so that's
actually interesting both of us at first
were like yeah it kind of is
like actually not it is to a point
and but then in terms of like
mechanistically how to deal with the
problem right it's not
solution-wise it's not but causewise it
is the point is
incomplete application of either
a vaccine or an antibiotic
causes the thing that you're trying to
fight to
evolve a sophistication that it doesn't
currently have so
yes yes it's analogous to that point and
then what you do about it i think is not
analogous yeah i agree i think that's
right
um i'm half vaccinated and concerned do
you know anything about the common
supplement nac
apparently can rescue tissue damage
caused by ace ii down regulation
i love you both dearly saludos desde
pittsburgh
um i don't know nac i don't know i
included it because i thought it's
possible you did
i don't so i appreciate the support but
we don't know anything about it
um really appreciate all your content
especially introducing gear to the
conversation good vibes
dearest professors thanks for fielding
my fun question mark ufo question last
week
hardly recommend terry verts and chris
mellenconvo on ufos
unity and attitudes towards science ufo
is rapidly becoming darkhorse path to
game b
oh cool interesting yeah actually i
forgot to pursue that i was working on a
bunch of other stuff this week but
i'm curious to see what was it the dod
that released some stuff about
possible ufos fascinating
do you know i don't i mean this stuff is
happening regularly i'm not even sure
which
revelation oh there was some giant thing
last week that we got this question
about
yeah we didn't know anything about the
particular oh you're asking if that one
was dod
yeah i don't i don't remember yeah is
there still time to tweak the title of
your upcoming book to
the hunter-gatherers guide to the 21st
century an homage to
douglas adams so um
i was on uh greg ellis's the respondent
and we actually had this conversation
back in march but he just released it
this week
and i was reminded that he actually when
he asked me about the book
he said it reminded him of the title
reminded him of hunter-gatherer's guide
to
no of the hunter have a hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy
and i said to him wow it literally had
never occurred to me before the cadence
like it just had
never occurred to me it's one of my
favorite books ever i don't think that
that's the case i think when we
initially discussed it
it was certainly certainly on my mind
the connection which i like because
we're both
huge fans of the hitchhiker's guide i
really don't think it has ever occurred
to me
i'm sure we talked about it so why
didn't you
uh suggest the undergather is good 21st
century then
um in part because i don't think it fits
as well
okay maybe there'll be another one
maybe we'll write a second one maybe
somebody will write a competing one with
that title
um a better hunter gathers guy
a guide for better hunter-gatherers
greatly appreciate these discussions
guys thank you on a lighter note are you
watching david attenborough's new
netflix series
life in color excellent program no
i didn't i am not no i caught wind this
is
there was something about done under
covet or something i think
i i can't remember what it was but
anyway my curiosity was peaked but
didn't look into it cool okay one more
here and then we'll go to the next hour
here
um there's an article posted on the
bulletin of atomic scientist
z that mentions the possible u.s funding
of the wuhan lab and the virus being
created artificially do you have a
comment
um i suspect this is the one that we
refer to
um bulletin of atomic scientists yeah
for whatever reason
um he's he did his own medium i know
i iso okay so there's there's a thing on
bulletin atomic scientists from
um years ago that just basically
predicts that there will be an outbreak
that we talked about in an early
and early episode of dark horse um so
you were talking about you were saying
that nicholas wade's piece is also on
bulletin of atomic scientists i
certainly believe that i saw it there
and that basically it was just totally
news to me
taken from me yeah if you go there we'll
we'll answer this and i will
if it's not there i guess i'll and
that's the one that we should link to
in medium rather than the medium one
um
and that is yep okay there it is so zach
you can show
if you want so um this looks like
exactly the same piece that we were that
i read
or no we didn't read from but that we
talked about in the first hour yeah and
i
i will uh skip the brand scan then good
yeah it's expensive
lots of reasons to skip the brain scan
um i need to find safari zach did you
draw a line for me so i can find uh
which yes you did is
bushes is it bush or bosh gear
vandenbosch
yeah yeah zac says he pronounces it
is bush's concern about just sounds like
we're talking about the former president
or something right
um is bush's concern about over
vaccination for kovid
oh wait so that's that line isn't drawn
in the right place
um well i already we already oh
they just asked the question twice okay
um you said that racism might
so this is written in what my advisor
arnold kluge would have called
telegraphic style and i used to tell him
it was actually telepathic style
because he really needed telepathy to
know um so this is this is echo who
asks excellent questions but i may need
to help
interpreting what this says i'm going to
try it you said that racism
might be software based
you also said your genes are wired for
genocide
is it
wired force i don't know i don't know
what it means
well presumably uh we are being asked
about the conflict the apparent conflict
between these two assertions
and it isn't a real conflict because
your genes can predis so you're talking
about racism versus genocide
well let's put it this way genocide
requires
racism i think that's fair um
so the software
dictates whether or not you
pay heed to something that your genes
predispose you to be able to notice
right so in other words if and basically
it works like this
there are multiple different bases on
which cooperation
evolves the most ancient and deepest
is gene-based cooperation right which
manifests as kin selection and i would
argue lineage selection
in uh in in humans
actually in all creatures but especially
elaborated in humans
the second is
reciprocal altruism and reciprocal
altruism
actually allows you to profit by
collaborating with individuals to whom
you are not closely related
and then there's an elaboration on top
of that which is indirect reciprocity
so the point is one can train themselves
to collaborate on the basis of these
second two things and to ignore
the implications of the first and
to a large extent though not completely
we should do that
racism is bad the productivity and
camaraderie that come from putting race
aside
is excellent and if we can get everybody
on board with that plan
the world is better for it so in any
case the point is
because it's software it's alterable we
know that that's the case
but it doesn't mean that the underlying
genetic predisposition isn't there which
it clearly
is and how could it not be on the basis
that the whole game
which i would argue we should sideline
as soon as possible and as completely as
possible
the whole game is built out of genetic
competition
that's what evolution is about
uh what's your take on troopers honor
killings analysis
um i don't know i'm trying to remember
it yeah
i uh i don't remember exactly what he
what he argues um i'm trying to remember
i've had a conversation with david about
this but i don't remember it well enough
to comment
yeah um
so regarding your hypothesis on the
evolution of not straight sex
you've been teasing its release for over
a year now saying it's not the right
time could you please just rip the
band-aid off and share it
he's not going to no i am going to but
you know
here not now yeah he's not doing it
covet is not making this easy
i do think it's time but uh you know
we need a proper venue is our culture of
instant gratification a driving force
behind the current calls for instant and
radical change
were previous generations perhaps more
patient and more realistic in their
expectations for societal change
yes yeah it's not the only one i don't
know that it's the
it's the main one but it's it's one of
the uh
driving forces yes yes and it's
downstream of
a culture that has lost touch with um
doing physical stuff yes most people
don't have a model system in which they
can get realistic about what's actually
accomplishable and what time period it
would take to get to something of value
basically things are true as soon as the
powers that be accepted they are and
change the web page so that's right
um we've become unrealistic
the guy in the vehicle at the north
portland protest was beaten nearly to
death by the armed protesters
and there's a there's a link yeah i know
he's hospitalized
um still um it's a
it's a disaster yeah and that actually
that is quite an omission from what we
said
uh i was not sure what his condition was
i still i'm not sure i did know that
he's still hospitalized so
whatever happened was severe but yeah i
think we should have said more about
that and it just
didn't get said but we'll amend it here
caitlyn jenner is running for governor
against the current governor and she's
the reasonable one
earth needs to destroy us and try
dinosaurs again
we have dinosaurs and they kill other
dinosaurs babies
as discussed in the first hour yes
exactly
so but they aren't they don't seem to be
confused about sex though
no yeah so there's that
my second modernist shot is next week
sire coverage on the spike protein doing
damage on its own now considering
skipping it moderate seems to have the
worst highest incidence of side effects
what tradeoffs am i looking at
um so we are not going to
advise any you know any particular
course of action uh in general i would
say
um starting starting something that is
expected to have a
have a you know have two parts and
stopping in the middle
is dangerous uh you might be you know
partially
partially protected um i just i feel
like there are many
many possible risks to doing that um
yeah certainly you will get less of the
benefit so you have already in some
sense invested
half well presumably half
the risk from the vaccine
and it will get only a fraction of the
benefit if you don't complete the course
so
yeah actually i guess i i think that um
uh you've so what were the two
i lost now what you were the two things
that you said um
that there that there's the um the two
categories
the benefit of the immunity and
their second thing the uh the risk
yeah that was i thought that you i
thought you had a slightly different
category here but
um maybe
the risk of one versus two shots is
exactly half
it certainly seems like that is a
reasonable assumption whereas it also
seems like it's a reasonable assumption
that the benefit from the vaccine
is considerably less than half if you
get one and not both
of a of a two shot deal that has been
uh described through you know hopefully
careful research as
um the two shots bring the benefit and
then there is also
the uh the other thing which is
you have it's always the other thing
yeah there's always the other thing
but you've taken half the risk let's say
it's half the risk because we don't know
that it's not and i think
mechanistically it makes sense that it
would be yeah um
[Music]
but the benefit of being vaccinated
you know i am not in favor of with
these vaccines and these authorities and
this disease i'm not in favor of
vaccine passports but given that they
are likely coming
and that there are other things below
that threshold that will likely be
controlled in this basis there's also
the question of
uh is it worth you know for half
the risk is it worth completing the
series yeah and i actually i actually
the more i think about it the more i
feel like maybe it's half the risk that
you've already
accepted but actually um
my guess would be that
your body has now demonstrated an
ability to to accommodate
right and that's that's not entirely
true right like we know that there are a
lot more side effects after the second
dose and all of this but
as far as we can see as far as we are
being shown the data
um it's not that all the serious stuff
that happens very very rarely
so far um is only after the second dose
so um i think actually having taken the
first dose and having
had a a response to it you already now
have whatever you know possible
long-term side effects they're going to
happen
you know maybe half as much maybe long
term but you have a much
lower protection from the vaccine that
you would have if you took both doses so
um i think i think my sense is
um really you should you should follow
up
and and i won't say what you should do i
would say
in your shoes even though i'm very
cautious about the vaccines i would
probably get the second one
um given the net net net but i you know
i think partially what you should get
out of this is that two people who have
some idea what this landscape
looks like and where the costs and
benefits are likely to be are faced with
what we don't want to be faced with
which is uh welcome to complex systems
kind of an answer which is you know look
with respect to
something like a long-term autoimmunity
problem
right uh maybe you've already paid the
price with the first
with respect to a tissue damage and
decreased longevity
issue probably it's 50 50 between two
shots of the same volume
and the reason i say that is in this
case you've got the weird fact of the
delivery mechanism
not displaying the antigen to the immune
system so the only way if i understand
this correctly the only way for that
second
shot to have any value at all to have
any effect on the system
is for it to be taken up by new cells
and
transcribed into spike protein which is
then displayed
and presumably reacted to more quickly
more quickly and maybe more broadly but
uh
you know so anyway you've got several
different kind of you know you've got
autoimmunity
you've got tissue damage and then you've
got
unknown other right like tumors and
who knows what else yeah right and uh
very hard to say but
on the other hand it's not like the
vaccines don't create
substantial immunity to covid which is
very dangerous
yeah and that immunity appears to be
highly protective
yep yep and effective yeah at least for
now
um you talked previously about the
evolution of hugs
what about romantic mouth to mouth uh
kisses oh just to kiss it's simple sir
i thought that was gonna be romantic
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation which i've
never heard of
kisses um just try to yeah
i don't know they're awesome i mean
uh what's the question do you know what
the question is what's the what's the
evolution
um i'm just trying to think uh chimp's
kiss
actually kind of kind of they kind of do
actually they definitely hug um
i think they kiss but i always do
everything so you just gotta leave them
out of this analysis
um i don't know the next you know
gorilla
you have to wonder in the case of chimps
whether chimps
normally kiss or it's only after they
get internet access and
you think it's porn related i wasn't
thinking of porn i was thinking of
higher quality stuff i figured chimps
were probably more discerning than that
but
you've you haven't met champs i guess
[Laughter]
um but gibbons maybe
gibbons would be more discerning than
that i wonder if gibbons
hug or kiss they certainly have the arms
for it yeah totally oh absolutely yeah
um
you know i wondered about this a little
bit and there's the
obvious uh you've wondered about whether
or not gibbons kiss
no now i have
i didn't get very far but all right um
yeah i've wondered about the evolution
of kissing of course and you know so is
everybody because there is of course
so does everybody know everybody has not
no kind of they have
because you know because there are these
uh apocryphal i believe
stories about uh inuit's rubbing noses
and slipping and
you know stuff like that so i've never
heard this you've never heard like the
accidental discovery of kissing yeah
oh come on exactly exactly so
um anyway i do think everybody's given
this some thought at some point and then
abandoned it and i probably gave it a
little more thing
it's the fictional 19th century
anthropologist who made up those stories
right well anyway i i did i do wonder if
there's not
a you know it uh obviously
causes the exchange
of uh not
gut flora but uh mouth flora you need to
logical information
yeah potentially but you know there's
there is some possibilities if you can
smell someone's mhc can you taste it
yeah something like that something like
that possibly
um so anyway there there's something to
be said for the possibility that there
is something actually
uh chemically important or
bacteriologically important that goes on
i would say you know the null hypothesis
is that no that's not what it's about
but
um and that therefore what it's about is
the tactile
uh thing but um but anyway yeah i would
say
i would say it's a it's a good it's a
good question
um oh boy we're not gonna click on this
link now but um
check out science friday's bumbling of
the trans legislation coverage
of course i did check out science
friday's bumbling of the trans
legislation
and then the question is which media
outlets will talk honestly about this
topic
um yeah not many and oh my god
sarah silverman came out on the wrong
side of this this week
um like i just feel like this is one of
the most obvious
this is one of the most obvious issues
that we are contending with as a society
right now
well actually a number of the things
that we have talked about today
remind me of this basic principle which
is that
certain stories diagnosed the system
right
right the fact that the new york times
and actually the mainstream press
couldn't figure out what to do with the
evergreen story diagnosed
the problem right if all you had to do
was diagnose the problem with the media
right all you had to know was what
actually happened which is fascinating
you would expect the media to be all
over it because they like fascinating
stuff right
um they weren't all over it oh so
there's something going on there that
makes this story impossible to report
okay so that tells you what's going on
and
the trans story is exactly this right
you have a genuine and very broadly
shared
desire to be compassionate that then
quickly runs into trade-offs right
am i compassionate with people who
genuinely find themselves feeling that
they are trapped in the wrong body and
want to transition i
very much want to help such a person i
get what that would be like and it would
not be easy
right on the other hand do i want women
protected
from predatory men who want to avail
themselves of a protected status
yes i do and there are more of them
but it's a more generic story so the
point is you can see how
people who have some simple heuristic
trip over this
and find themselves saying something in
order to defend
one or the other category and they can't
see the nuance and
but i mean it also this feels even
simpler
like to me men who
self-identify as women without even any
requirement for
hormones or or surgery and therefore get
to go into women's crisis centers and
and prisons is really obvious
um lee a problem but you know
you know some number of those men are
just looking for a you know a better
situation
and some number of them really do
suddenly realize that they feel like
women
whatever this one seems even simpler
like the trans legislation thing that is
being talked about i assume although i
haven't
seen this particular coverage is about
trans women in women's sports
it's about sports which you just have to
have been on the planet for
i don't know through puberty to
recognize
that men and women are different and
you know maybe you need to have thought
about it a tiny bit
to recognize that actually all that
stuff
that has been making the male pathway
and the female pathway pathway different
since literally since fertilization is
not reversible with a simple switch a
simple toggle
of you know some puberty blockers and
some hormones and even some surgery
no not reversible it doesn't work that
way well
okay this is obvious to us and it will
be
hopefully obvious to anybody who's paid
attention to what we've said on this
topic
uh for any length of time but you can
imagine
the problem is heuristics right yeah
people are used to navigating by
heuristics and the fact is
people do it because heuristics are in
general so freaking useful
right but in the case that
let's imagine you were having a dinner
party right
a hundred people and some of those
people yeah i'm sorry
it's a hypothetically you're not gonna
have to do no one has hundred people
dinner parties in this century i don't
think
that's not at dinner you're right that's
like a wedding you're right
all right let's suppose you're having a
dinner party
with three people it's more by style
yeah no totally it is for your style
yeah um no let's
let's imagine it's 20 people okay you're
having a dinner party
right i'm having a dinner party 20
people
i'm invited and i may come okay it's
barbecue
because i can do that yeah um but all
right so
the point is there's a dinner party and
every one of your guests
saved two my guests saved two
uh are totally on board with
treating our trans friend who will be
present
uh exactly as they would hope to be
treated
right and then did i say two friends or
exceptions
you did and we have two friends who are
overly fond
of you know the kind of
ben shapiro approach to this where
they're
you know aggressive about pointing out
the ways in which
transness is not a complete
transformation etc
and the point is you can imagine a
desire to get everybody on board with
the majority in that case
and their willingness to behave
kindly towards your guest being nice
actually gets us where we need to go in
this situation the right thing to do
right and so the point is okay we can
see the situation also our bathrooms are
already co-ed spaces
they're really single person space well
this is the point like these things
don't scale so people imagine your
dinner party and then they're like well
right so that'll just work it happens we
don't have a prison
our bathrooms work for either sex
right it doesn't you don't even have to
tell us what sex you identify
as when you go in no signs on the doors
right exactly so this is all very simple
it's just a matter of getting everybody
to behave in the same courteous way okay
then you build a heuristic from that and
the point is look
treat people how they want to be treated
it's the right thing to do right it's a
good heuristic until you get to sports
prisons and all of the other things that
force you to actually engage a deeper
question what's going on with sarah
silverman she wrote a heuristic
right that heuristic has now been gamed
and well but she also and you know maybe
maybe this just came after the heuristic
you may be exactly right but
um i i think i just saw like a 30 second
clip of
of her going off on this this week in
exactly the wrong position
um you know she says well you know why
don't we segregate sex by height
that's like okay you you are
con i think that there's a conflation of
individual versus population level stuff
but if you're really arguing that we
shouldn't be segregating sex
i mean sport by sex and that is just as
artificial as segregating sport by
height
i think i misspoke last time then you're
arguing for all co-ed sports
which is the end of women in sport at
least at the professional level right
like
you know because because with a very few
exceptions like
maybe long distance running like super
long distance running like
hyper long distance running like 100
miles men will out-compete women
in in feats of you know raw power and
speed and strength they just
will and you know like why don't we
segregate sports by height well like
um you know some some sports
you effectively do basketball
effectively does and they sideline
everybody
basketball sidelines everybody who isn't
tall and boxing does
segregate by weight yep right right and
so it depends it depends on the sport
but in
every case again with the maybe maybe
possible exception
of extreme long-distance running um
there's just
there's differences and if you don't
segregate by sex then that's the end of
women's sports and is that really what
you want
well i can't remember where it happened
it may have been in one of the patreon
discussions or it may have been on dark
horse maybe in a q a
but i actually believe that this topic
is going to bring about the
end of sport as we know it
because these questions actually are
difficult
right so if you know if you
in the original case you have
a genetic lottery you get whatever
endowment you have genetically then you
make whatever you can
of it you get good at things you develop
skills um
you innovate new techniques whatever and
that is exciting to see
play out on a soccer field or whatever
right who's really good at this game who
knows something other people don't know
who's you know better at intuiting the
dynamics on the field whatever it is
right but
and then you get to doping right oh well
i can take what i was genetically
awarded and i can
augment it in this way i can borrow from
my future self and i can enrich myself
in the present by doing it literally
enrich
right and so i can basically cheat and
then there's a arms race about can you
cheat in such a way that we can't see
that that's what you're doing
but it you know the point is uh we're
not in kansas anymore at the point that
that
takes over your sport and then you get
into questions about well
why don't we have height classes and
have
four basketball leagues is a game of
short people playing
against you know on a court with short
baskets less
exciting what if they're more talented
that could be really interesting
right and so the point is you get into
this never-ending
sequence of like well what really is
athletic talent and the point is well
one thing it is at the point you're
parsing how much of it is genes and how
much of it is economics incentives and
all of this thing is it's just a lot
less fun
so i wonder if it isn't all going to
come apart as a result of this
and if you know i don't think that means
it's the end of
athleticism i think what it means is
athleticism will be reborn in
probably a more interesting way and i i
would put on the table
you know olympic gymnastics
those are really talented people doing
something really boring
right it's like sort of exciting to see
that a person can do that but it's very
hard to distinguish one routine from the
next that subtleties
you have to be an expert to detect most
of them right and so the point is
well the the
sorry the distinction we've made before
is between that
and and watching a great parkour routine
exactly and the point is
you can't compare two parkour routines
in the same way it's subjective but once
you sign up for okay i accept that it's
subjective
it's much more interesting and very
demanding i mean this
we should do a whole episode on this or
more but you know there's a difference
between sport and athleticism
right because athleticism isn't
inherently competitive and sport is
and so like athleticism plus competition
gets you to sport
and um some of the things that we
have in the olympics for instance have
seemed to many of us for a long time and
you know we're hardly the first people
to point out it's like
is that really sport like does
competition really belong there
and if so like on what basis is it being
judged and
you know maybe it just you know i i we
we went to um what was it like the x
games is that what it's called once not
the x games that's wrong
um the the like the the games
once uh with a lot of like it was
parkour
and it was bmx bikers and um
skateboarders and you know outside in
san francisco once many years ago
camera what they're called um this is
obvious but um
anyway um yes they were being judged
it was there's no simple metric right
like this is the
with regard to competition the world
wants a simple metric a simple
linear variable speed um
you know speed down the hill uh number
you know speed down the hill or speed
through the thing in combination with
this many
jumps or this much time in the air like
that you just add metric after metric
after metric
um but at the end of the day it's like
okay those four guys who just did that
were all awesome and for me watching
those like i never care about like who
is declared the winner but of course in
order for
the market to work and for there to be a
game for us to go see
a competition for us to go see there has
to be someone who's declared the winner
whereas
you know basketball uh with an
established height
which no isn't three feet lower for
shorter p i don't know how much it would
have to be lower you know a foot and a
half lower for shorter people
would be a different game could be it
could be an interesting game but then
then you have to start imposing height
limits right yes
and so you know there really is a
difference between
play and sport and sport and athleticism
and we conflate them all and
the fact is that men and women are going
to have different facilities and yes
some sports really give themselves to
um co-ed i mean i have talked before
about
ultimate how much we both love playing
ultimate and like i specifically having
played
competitively on women's teams and
watched at those same tournaments
a lot of men's teams and played a lot of
uh co-ed
always preferred the co-ed games they
were just more interesting to be part of
always and it's structured to work
structures
don't dominate the women in those games
even though the usual athletic
comparison still applies
yes yes exactly but some some games some
kinds of
sport some kinds of games won't work
that way yep no most don't
most don't um i will say just
my last contribution here is that i do
think we have kind of a societal
pathology surrounding what you were
discussing
with respect to our desire to have a
metric that we can exactly compare
yeah and you actually see this in lots
of places
you know if you follow cameras and you
watch the absurd
there are certain things it's production
dominate right
but that you know i i realized in
teaching
specifically because evergreen freed us
to do whatever we needed to do in order
to get the job done
that actually there was a uh
a world open to us
once you accept the subjectivity of
evaluation yeah and the fact is i don't
think
what i was doing was any more subjective
than what mostly gets done but
people have this pseudo-quantification
mechanism
where you know well you're going to turn
in an essay and then i'm going to give
you
you know points out of a hundred and
then i'm going to put the number in my
book
and then at the end of the term we're
going to count those numbers and the
point is
i don't know if most people use numbers
for essays but
whatever they do yeah it amounts to
pseudo-quantification and the point is
look as long as you've got a layer in
there that's subjective
your thing is subjective yeah now if you
don't own up to that
yeah right now this is huge i mean this
is a
second vastly important topic one of
pseudo
uh quantification and one in which and i
think the more enumerate you are the
more easily you are fooled when numbers
are
presented to you and so the more likely
you are to think when you get
presented with like here's a ranking
here's the answers
here's what the data say um and you're
like oh
well there's numbers this must be the
truth like actually
um often though none of that was
legitimate because there was some trick
somewhere in there and sometimes it's
intentional as soon as it's not
often people just don't have any idea
that you can't
you you can't turn those subjective
things over there
into numbers and then and pretend that
it was quantitative all the time
the whole time right and the thing is
you know basketball is kind of objective
if you've got referees it's all done in
public the referees judge
the rules the rules are known to
everybody and how many times you know
within the rules the the
ball goes through the basket dictates
the number of points so that isn't one
of these things but so many things
baseball nor soccer or football right
right
so those those things are not of this
nature but the number of things that
are subjective and pretend to be
something else by virtue of some
hand-waving argument for making them
objective is
shocking and the degree to which things
get more interesting once you say okay
subjectivity that's part of this one
yeah it doesn't
it doesn't make parkour less interesting
to watch right right it's subjective but
wow are those people talented and that's
some pretty amazing stuff you wouldn't
think you could do
all right um so many questions we must
be over an hour at this point zach yes
okay let me just find one or two more
here uh to
to wrap it up um
by 2040 here's one by 2040
this is a four-part question so i'll get
to these because we're going to have to
come back to this next week anyway
by 2040 plant-based and cultured meats
are set to account for 60 percent of the
market
the industry is expected to be ready for
mass production and massively decrease
animal meat as early as 2025.
wait wait we go back plant-based and
what else means cultured
so lab mate yeah got it um
coincidence i don't have we talked about
labmate here i'm not sure we have
okay we both feel strongly about it yeah
we have an opinion about lab mate
um but i'll just start over by 2040
plant-based and cultured meats are set
to account for 60
of the market the industry is expected
to be ready for mass production and
massively decrease animal meat as early
as 2025.
coincidentally bill gates is heavily
invested in all meat technologies and is
now the single largest owner of farmland
in the us with 14 000 acres combine this
with the biden tax and climate plans and
well
that may be all she wrote for the
american farmer i wish more people would
look into this
have a restful mother's day so long and
thanks for all the fish
um the ps here's a farmer explaining the
business end of this
and there's a youtube video i do i do
worry for
the future of farming and farmers
one of the things this is not exactly
responsive i have no idea
about bill gates and his involvement
here i just can't speak to that i have
heard that there's a few tech
billionaires buying up a lot of farmland
and what does that mean
i'm concerned about that but um one of
the things that we
were lucky enough to see and sort of be
part of when we were at evergreen was
that there was an ag there was an
organic farm and there was an active
agriculture and sustainable agriculture
program and a food program and
we had students who
were chefs and farmers and growers and
producers and
you know and and and ferment producers
and all sorts of things
um and what do you do now keep talking
i'm gonna look up something relevant
while we're at this um
you're giving me crazy looks off camera
no i wouldn't um
uh and you know we we arrived
in olympia already being interested in
buying as much of our food from
um you know as direct with as few
middlemen as possible and
um we just there as here we
had a piece of property that had almost
no sun because i had so much trees so we
couldn't grow our own but we grew from
the farmers when we could
um and um you know and would
occasionally for instance buy
a half a cow um and you know keep it in
our freezer
um having been butchered appropriately
um and
and ate that way and it was marvelous to
see
and also uh heartbreaking to hear the
stories
as you know even even there you started
to see the encroachment you know how
what what slim profit margins um these
these guys were
working on and um the encroachment by
in the case of olympia it was mostly not
um you know it wasn't big ag it was it
was development
you know it was just the demand for the
for the land in order to put houses on
it as opposed to grow strawberries
was huge um and you know this
i've been thinking about this to some
degree since i was a kid because my dad
grew up on a on a farm in iowa
and um you know that farm in
northeastern iowa and that farm and like
all the rest around them have now been
subsumed into you know giant corporate
pig farms basically
um and uh it is it is not
it is not good for the consumers of the
food and it's not good
long term for the american economy as
well and it's not good for the animals
because of the animals it's not good for
the soil it's not about the environment
yeah
it's it's a disaster the scale of the
thing is incredible and dangerous and
completely inhumane and unacceptable
yeah um did you find what you were
looking for yes i did i just wanted to
point out that we have a follower who is
expert in this realm and i wanted to
make sure that i had our last name
right ariel greenwood who uh anyway
i've been in periodic touch with over a
number of a number of years anyway she
is a sustainable
farmer of means who i'm sure would have
um interesting things to say about this
very thing and perhaps we should find
out what she does have to say
i will say i don't like seeing plant
meat and cultured meat
grouped because i don't think there's
anything inherently wrong
with making a hamburger patty out of
black beans and
whatever yeah i think that's fine yeah
i'm not
sure that the best way to think of it is
as this is
meat right um but whatever you know it's
plant-based food
yeah on the other hand i think this lab
meat thing is going to be awful and that
the way it is being sold
is um you know predictable
but it's going to be gross and it's
going to be bad for you
worse than meat and frankly i don't
think meat is inherently
especially bad for you unless you eat
too much of it but
or it was eating it it was fed a lot of
antibiotics and glyphosate ridden grass
and you know all this
right or yeah i was eating the wrong
thing um so that's probably not grass
it was physio physiologically stressed
or or whatever but
anyway i do think there's a way to do
meat that is humane and
healthy and there's a way to overdo it
with any meat but
and it's hard to do it to scale given
how many people want meat
well but i mean you know that's the
thing is we have to recognize that
actually
meat should be more expensive because
each animal
deserves to have a decent life until its
life is over
and that has costs and that should
result in us eating
less meat and uh that's not the same
thing as saying it has to be zero or
it's inhumane or whatever yep
but but yeah why don't we so maybe this
is where we should
excuse me this is we should where we
should stop but let us
uh spell out a little bit what exactly
the objection to lab meat is you said
you think it's going to be
unpalatable and dangerous well i take
back the unpalatable things slightly
because i have the sense
that whatever it is that makes you know
a burger king
hamburger taste good without actually
being a defensible production mode
can probably be done here too in other
words um
the the um supply chain issue with
something like a fast food hamburger
results in a gray flavorless patty
by virtue of the long route that it's
taken
yada yada so what do they do they
enhance the flavor in other ways
and the point is actually they get to
something that does simulate the taste
of meat so i'm not sure that they can't
do that with lab meat but it's not the
same thing as oh lab meat tastes
just as good as a steak and in fact
it's effectively guaranteed not to right
because the fact is part of what makes a
steak a steak is not just the genes that
make the cells that make the steak it's
the fact that the steak walked around
and did stuff
and right that's exactly right i i'm
actually
i'm shocked at how few people seem to
get this right
well but now we're going to get when
that steak was walking around doing
stuff we called it a cow but
that part where it was a cow was
actually really important to what it
tastes like when it's on your plate
right well
it was doing stuff yeah and you know
game tastes different than
uh than be from a cow right and that's
because it does different stuff in large
measure
um but so they're people halfway through
their angry email to us about the fact
that
the lab meet people know this and
they've got exercise regimes
yeah they're prodding it with electrodes
to get the electrical impulses to go
through it as if they were running
through the landscape
right so anyway uh mark my words
it might taste good but it'll taste good
for reasons that have nothing to do with
the lab meat itself somebody should do a
taste test
with the actual lab meat in order to see
what that tastes like
uh and that will be gross and uh
it will also be bad for you and it may
take a while to get there
but you can see it coming decades ahead
you can just
see it coming and you can imagine the
papers that will ultimately be written
about the shocking discovery that
actually this isn't so good for you and
all of the people who are returning to
traditional meat and the farms that are
starting up because people have
discovered
that that whole trend was in the end not
a good idea that's all coming
right it's just if we get that far right
yes except for the fact that the future
may have been canceled but other than
that it's coming
yeah oh well this has been hopeful as
always
yeah as always um oh so here's what
we'll end on
here is 20 because i asked two questions
in one
there we go nice thank you i don't
remember what your questions were
but uh appreciated i feel that they were
ethical questions
to be sure this person obviously
has has those yes has ethos
will travel yes um well this has been
weird
i would like to think i played no role
in that this has been weird today
um but here we are we will be back next
week um
in the meantime please subscribe like go
over to the clips channel subscribe like
there
join us at one of our patreons consider
buying yourself a dark horse t-shirt
we may at some point have some new
merchandise out i hope so yes and limit
yourself to
one cup of lab meat a week until the
data is in
[Music]
data the data are in oh
god i'm never living that down never
never
um so by all means um love
love the people uh who you love and eat
good food not a cup of lab meat
and get outside be well everyone
you